[Music]
with chapter 17 we come to a major
turning point at the decline and fall
really it's the turning point chapter 14
ended with Constantine assuming one-man
rule and preparing to make two momentous
changes first change was founding a
brand new capital at Constantinople
which would permanently move the center
of gravity of the Empire and the second
change was the establishment of
Christianity as the official religion
this radically new story will be the
subject of chapter 17 through 21 earlier
Gibbon had not bothered to describe the
city of Rome in any depth many of his
readers would have been there in person
most were probably familiar with
travelers accounts Constantinople was
more exotic and it had unique features
that needed to be understood though I
never saw a Constantinople Gibbon
describes it in such rich detail you
would swear he had lived there
Constantine shows an exceptional sight
for his city on the western or European
shore of the Bosphorus that's the narrow
strait that gives access from the Sea of
Marmara to the Black Sea to the west and
others Strait gives access to the
Mediterranean back then it was called
the Hellespont today it's the
Dardanelles Constantinople was thus
situated right where major trade routes
passed through both by sea and by land
its harbor was known as the Golden Horn
on account of the curved shape of the
shoreline but also Gibbon says because
the epithet of golden was expressive of
the riches which every wind wafted from
the most distant countries into the
secure and capacious port of
Constantinople in 1846 three years
before literal gold was discovered in
California
John C Fremont had this in mind when he
named the entrance to San Francisco Bay
to this gate Fremont declared I gave the
name of Chris awfully or Golden Gate for
the same reason that the harbor at
Bruges an tiem was
called Chris acerous or Golden Horn the
Greek name didn't catch on we don't
speak of the krisily bridge in the
distant past a small settlement on the
site had been named Byzantium and
eventually the name Byzantine was
applied to the empire in the east for a
long time however its rulers continued
to call themselves Roman emperors as for
Constantinople no one ever called it
Byzantium until historians in the 16th
century did and by then the city had a
new name the one it still bears Istanbul
conferred by the Ottoman Turks after
they captured it in 1453 the development
of gunpowder and cannons was what made
their victory possible until then for
over a thousand years
no attacker was able to break through
the massive city walls
although Constantine won his initial
victory at Rome in 312 he had to go on
battling various rivals for another 12
years
finally in 324 his rule was secure and
he was able to establish a remarkably
efficient system of government Gibbon
gives a detailed account of the complex
bureaucracy along with reorganized
taxation reform of the judiciary and
reining in of the dangerous Praetorian
guards their leaders were relieved of
military duties and transformed into
civilian prefect in charge of
administrative regions all over the
Empire in the capital much of the
administration was carried out by
eunuchs who were highly competent but
represented a class of men or not quite
men there was always regarded with
revulsion in Rome from Gibbons point of
view the Empire was now ruled by an
oriental despotism and no longer paid
even lip service to the pretense that
the emperor carried out the wishes of
the Senate Constantine himself was a
band of the east his father had been an
Army officer in the Balkans and his own
career began at the court of Diocletian
at nikka media in Asia Minor
after his victory in 312 he visited Rome
only one more time during his life to
celebrate the 10th anniversary of his
accession that was when he dedicated the
arch of Constantine that still dominates
the site of the forum not far from the
Colosseum during this period the
distinction between citizens inside the
empire and barbarians outside was
getting increasingly blurred many former
barbarians had settled down comfortably
inside the Empire and it needed them the
only way to keep the enormous army fully
manned was to recruit barbarian soldiers
with the promise of good pay and gifts
of land when their service was finished
Gibbon says darkly the introduction of
barbarians into the Roman armies became
every day more Universal more necessary
and more fatal how far this is from the
idealized picture at the beginning of
the decline and fall when an army of
citizen soldiers was commanded by senior
patricians we mentioned on an earlier
occasion that the empire had a command
economy driven not by commercial
competition but by expenditure on the
army and on luxuries such as opulent
palaces and expensive public displays
the theater is in chariot races of
Constantinople were famous after
detailed calculations Gibbon concludes
that an individual taxpayer in those
days must have paid four times as much
as an eighteenth-century Frenchman would
the collection of taxes was highly
efficient but the uses they were put to
was not given says that the inequity
this entailed may be rendered more
evident by comparison of the present
state of France as it is now governed by
the absolute monarch of an industrious
wealthy and affectionate people Jacques
Necker the husband of Gibbons former
fiancee Susan was the finance minister
of Louis the sixteenth and Gibbon had
undoubtedly talked over the subject with
him when he stayed with the knickers in
Paris
as for the affectionate
people this description was published in
1781 in 1789 the French people would
turn out not to be so affectionate after
all to given the term oriental implied
not just despotism but also an emphasis
on flashy images rather than substance
so he tells us indignantly Asiatic pomp
assumed in air softness and effeminacy
and the person of Constantine he is
represented with false hair of various
colors laborious ly arranged by the
skillful artists at the time a diadem of
a new and more expensive fashion a
profusion of gems and pearls of collars
and bracelets and a variegated flowing
robe of silk most curiously embroidered
with flowers of gold in such apparel
scarcely to be excused by the youth and
folly of Elagabalus we're at a loss to
discover the wisdom of an agent monarch
and the simplicity of a Roman veteran s
Gibbon sees it this ostentatious display
was not just stage II posturing it was
moral rot so although Constantine began
life as a tough army officer by now he
was a complacent autocrat surrounded by
sycophants Gibbon draws the morale with
what if his splendidly analytical
sentences a mind thus relaxed by
prosperity and indulgence was incapable
of rising to that magnanimity which
disdained suspicion and dares to forgive
magnanimity still had its Latin meaning
greatness of soul Constantine had become
selfish at petty and with an
increasingly paranoid fear of imagined
enemies he no longer dared to forgive he
began to suspect his wife Fausto and his
son Crispus might conspire against him
and shockingly he had to put to death
from a political point of view the
degenerate ethos of the court was bound
to infect the administration that
started out so promising Lee as Gibbon
describes it Constantine's
worthy favorite enriched by the
boundless liberality of their master
usurped with impunity the privilege of
rappin and corruption a secret that
universal decay was felt in every part
of the public administration like the
slow poisoning of the Empire of the West
the slow decay was rotting the Empire in
the East we will say more in later
lectures about the reaction modern
historians have to this negative
attitude of Gibbons whether or not the
Eastern Empire was decaying it would
still outlast the western empire by
fully a thousand years
Christmas was Constantine's son by a
first wife with Faust uh he had three
more sons whom he allowed to survive and
it is death in 337 they were the heirs
to the throne confusingly their names
were Constantine Constantius and
Constance was also a sister named
Constantina
their struggle for supremacy occupies a
long narrative by Gibbon which we will
not attempt to follow here a new wave of
barbarians came on the scene at this
point called SAR missions they had
originated in Central Asia and now
inhabited the region known as Cynthia
corresponding to modern Ukraine and
southern Russia they were a nomadic
people and has given describes them more
literally barbarous than the Goths and
Franks had been lacking iron and he says
they were reduced to the necessity of
employing fishbones
for the points of their weapons but the
custom of dipping them in a venomous
liquor that poisoned the wounds which
they inflicted is alone sufficient to
prove the most savage manners their
shaggy beards and uncombed locks the
furs with which they were covered from
head to foot and their fierce
countenances which seemed to express the
innate cruelty of their minds inspired
the more civilized provincials of Rome
with horror and dismay by the end of
chapter 19 we've gained a good
understanding of the Empire under
Constantine
as well as of rivalries and wars that
broke out after he died in 337 probably
in his early 60s the date of his birth
is uncertain yet we have still not heard
anything about his conversion to
Christianity it comes at last into the
foreground in chapter 20 Gibbon is now
ready to address two big questions the
first is why did the pagan Constantine
convert to Christianity and make it the
official religion and the second
question is why did furious theological
debate immediately erupt and become a
major factor in public life as to why
Constantine established Christianity
most people in Gibbons day would have
thought the answer was obvious Samuel
Johnson explained it like this the hour
came at length when after 300 years of
struggle and distress truth took
possession of imperial power as to why
theological debate got so intense well
people like Johnson would regard that as
obvious to human beings have an
obligation to interpret and teach the
truths as well as they can but since
people are fallible disagreements are
bound to arise Gibbon would not have
been impressed with either of those
answers as with his earlier account of
the rise of Christianity he approaches
these questions from the perspective of
a secular historian actually it's not
clear that Constantine ever had a
conversion experience in the way that
Augustine did when he opened the Bible
in his garden Milan but later writers
very much wanted to believe there was a
decisive conversion and they attributed
it to a vision that constitute ena and
his soldiers supposedly witnessed just
before the crucial victory in 312
Constantine also had a dream which he
took his prophetic but of course that
was experienced by no one except himself
as to what really happened we are
dependent on inconsistent accounts by a
number of writers but especially a
bishop named Eusebius who knew
Constantine well and published a
biography of him shortly after his death
Eusebio
was an able historian he took seriously
the obligation to weigh evidence with
care but he certainly wanted to confirm
the working of divine providence and he
claimed he had irrefutable evidence
Constantine himself had described the
vision on his deathbed swearing with a
solemn oath that it was true as Eusebius
reports it when Constantine and his
troops were approaching Rome there
appeared in the sky a luminous cross and
a voice was heard to cry out in this
sign you shall conquer
Eusebius gives the words in Greek but in
their Latin form in hoc Signo Vinces
they became a central feature of
Christian tradition and are displayed
prominently in the Vatican today all of
the soldiers saw this phenomenon and
they went into battle certain that God
was on their side I've already seen how
skeptical Gibbon is about miracles and
this one is no exception so he tells us
the real or imaginary cause of so
important an event deserves and demands
the attention of posterity and he
promises to separate the historical the
natural and the marvelous parts of this
extraordinary story which he says in the
composition of a specious argument have
been artfully confounded in one splendid
and brittle mass specious fades
superficially plausible but not correct
as for the story that was artfully
presented by religious writers it was
actually brittle vulnerable to collapse
if he knew where to push it and as for
Gibbons word marvellous there's a big
difference between the merely marvelous
and the miraculous white Constantin have
made it all up
jebin considers that possibility he
notes that there must have been many
people still living whom Eusebius could
have interviewed but instead of getting
their testimony he relied simply on what
constitute himself had said give a notes
also that other religious writers in the
fourth and fifth centuries who evidently
had not seen you see Mises biography
made no man
- whatsoever of the wonderful vision
which was supposedly witnessed by an
entire army yet Gibbon is willing at
least to conclude that Constantine
believed he was telling the truth
whatever he saw or thought he saw he
probably did feel certain that he had
been given a special sign from God his
vanity Gibbon says was gratified by the
flattering assurance that he had been
chosen by heaven to reign over the earth
success had justified his divine title
to the throne and that title was founded
on the truth of the Christian revelation
Gibbon notes also that Constantine
waited to be baptized until he was on
his deathbed which he thought suspicious
modern historians tell us however that
that practice was far from uncommon
people knew they were likely to go on
committing sins after baptism and they
might fear they had endangered their
salvation by getting baptized at the
last possible moment they hope to
guarantee their welcome in heaven Gibbon
puts it more cynically by the delay of
their baptism they could venture freely
to indulge their passions in the
enjoyment of this world whatever
Constantine's vision may have been like
historians today tend to doubt just as
Gibbon did that he experienced at
overwhelming conversion in 312 his
commitment seems to have evolved only
gradually which is exactly what Gibbon
says the dices accuracy is required in
tracing the slow and almost
imperceptible gradations by which the
monarch declared himself the protector
and at length the proselyte of the
church now if Constantine wasn't a
fervent believer right from the start
why would he install Christianity as the
official religion - given the answer was
obvious a state religion could be a
valuable ally for political absolutism
which according to the Fela softs was
the role the Catholic Church still
played at 18th century France and unlike
the old paganism Christianity taught
obedience to Authority as a moral duty
together with patient acceptance of
suffering at this veil of
tears so Gibbon says the throne of the
Emperor's would be established on a
fixed and permanent basis if all their
subjects embracing the Christian
doctrine should learn to suffer and to
obey in a footnote Gibbon mentions a
piece of alleged evidence for the
worldly privileges of the Catholic
Church there was a document known as the
donation of Constantine in which
Constantine supposedly bestowed immense
powers on the Pope in the 15th century
however the donation of Constantine was
proved to be a forgery that was done by
a Catholic priest named Lorenzo valla
who showed that its language and
vocabulary belonged to a much later
period probably the eighth century and
the documents before that time never
once referred to it even though they
certainly would have if it existed ball
I had no intention of undermining the
faith his goal was simply to expose
self-serving deception on the part of
the institutional church Gibbon uses
similar arguments to undermine organized
religion in general whatever
Constantine's motives may have been this
was truly a turning point in history all
the more remarkable because it might
never have happened at all the historian
Michael Grant says this conversion of
the state was a rash and remarkable
personal venture one of the apocalyptic
acts of history which deny the modern
doctrine that everything happens in
personally the Empire became Christian
because of the unlikely emergence of a
Christian Emperor grant observes that
the Persian Empire had a great many
Christians in its population but there
was never a Christian monarch there and
Persia never became a Christian state
the consequence of this change was to
drastically alter the relationship of
power between church and state Peter
Brown puts it succinctly from being a
sect ranged against Roman civilization
Christianity became a church prepared to
absorb a whole society it didn't happen
all at once it wasn't
pleat until the rain of Theodosius the
first 40 years after Constantine but
right from the start as Gibbon says
bishops enjoyed legal as well as
spiritual jurisdiction there are no
fewer than 1,800 bishops in the Empire a
thousand of them in the East 800 in the
West Gibbon emphasizes the significance
of their new role while the civil and
military professions were separated by
the policy of Constantine a new one
perpetual order of ecclesiastical
ministers always respectable sometimes
dangerous was established in the church
and state in 325 just one year after
Constantine achieved unchallenged power
he convened a great Council of bishops
at Nicaea not far from Constantinople to
avoid confusion for readers as a decline
at fault I should mention Gibbon spells
it like the French city nice but he must
have pronounced it as two syllables nice
say not only did Constantine organized
this first Council of Nicaea he presided
over it personally and took an active
part in the debates with this military
background it's not clear how fully he
understood the theological issues what
he did understand was that there was a
lot of destructive quarreling about
Christian doctrine and he wanted it to
stop as we've already absurd pagan
religions didn't have theology at all
just communal practices what was doing
Christianity was an insistence of very
specific verbal formulas which one had
to accept in order to be a member of the
church but during the first two
centuries even the Bible was a far from
settled document with no central
authority as yet numerous competing
Gospels were in circulation in addition
to the four that eventually became
canonical likewise there are many more
epistles than were finally included in
the New Testament agreeing on a fixed
canon of biblical books and a stable set
of doctrines would be an immense
advantage for the church that was what
Constantine wanted a stable doctrine
that could be enforced throughout the
empire to ensure unit
the council of nicaea did do that
producing the nicene creed which became
standard in the catholic church and
eventually in some protestant ones as
well but it was by no means unchallenged
then or later further councils went on
trying to clarify and refine its meaning
and they were aggressive breakaway
groups that refused to accept it at all
those groups were denounced as heretics
and although it took a long time they
were eventually stamped out all we know
about them comes from brief quotations
probably chosen unfairly in the writings
of the winners given himself believed
hardly a word of the Creed if he even
believed that much as a boy though he
had enjoyed exploring theological
controversies as a kind of intellectual
game and now he tackled them again with
energy and skill he once remarked he
understood the meaning of the words
modern churchgoers recited much better
than they did themselves no less an
authority than John Henry Cardinal
Newman wrote in the 19th century its
melancholy to say it but the chief
perhaps the only English writer who has
any claim to be considered an
ecclesiastical historian is the
unbeliever Gibbon the debate at Nicaea
was complex and abstruse at its heart
was an issue which as Gibbon says the
author of the fourth gospel expressed in
philosophical language it was very
different from the language of the first
three Gospels according to st. John not
only had God become man but Christ was
himself the logos the word through which
the creation of the entire universe took
place in the King James translation the
Gospel of John begins in the beginning
was the word and the Word was with God
and the Word was God the same was in the
beginning with God all things were made
by him and without him was not anything
made that was made
the idea of an eternal logos animating
the entire universe was platonic or in
technical terms neo
tonic but there was a huge philosophical
problem in the Christian claim that the
logos was incarnated in an individual
person in Bethlehem and then put to
death in Jerusalem that made no sense at
all to the Greek mind as st. Paul
acknowledged in the First Epistle to the
Corinthians we preach Christ crucified
Paul said under the Jews a
stumbling-block and unto the Greeks
foolishness Gibbon puts the paradox in a
nutshell the Christian revelation he
says disclose to the world the amazing
secret that the logos who was with God
from the beginning and was God who had
made all things and for whom all things
had been made was incarnate in the
person of Jesus of Nazareth who had been
born of a virgin and suffered death on
the cross the solution that theologians
came up with was the doctrine of the
Trinity which has never explicitly
mentioned as such in the New Testament
in the Gospel of Matthew Jesus commands
his followers to go forth to all nations
in the name of the Father and of the Son
and of the Holy Spirit that's not a
theological statement about the precise
relationship among those three entities
but theological statements were what the
Council of Nicaea was determined to
establish for all time as translated in
the Book of Common Prayer authorised in
1662 by the Church of England the Nicene
Creed describes Christ as begotten not
made being of one substance with the
Father by whom all things were made that
little expression one substance was the
crux it Nicaea and long afterward a
rival strain of Christianity known as
Arianism asserted that Jesus must have
been created by God the Father and was
therefore subordinate to the Father not
fully divine the bishops at Nicaea
rejected that interpretation in the
Creed they produced Jesus was begotten
not made but then doesn't begetting
imply that the father did exist before
the son to rule out that interpretation
they added the concept of one substance
the Father the Son and the Spirit work
on substantial sum how sharing a single
substance it Greek the term was
homoousios this may look like verbal
nitpicking but actually the stakes were
very high if the Sun were not identical
to the Father
it might look all too much like a return
to polytheism the sworn enemy of
Christianity that is clearly what
arianism looked like the Orthodox
bishops at Nicaea the term Orthodox
later came to be associated with the
Eastern Church but the basic meaning of
Orthodox is simply correct opinion
similarly the term Catholic came to be
associated with the Church of the West
but its basic meaning is universal far
from putting an end to debate the
Council of Nicaea just stimulated debate
in later years a series of further
councils which keeps struggling to get
everything nailed down with obvious
sarcasm Gibbon says in the last words of
chapter 20 the progress of time and
superstition erased the memory of the
weakness the passion the ignorance which
disgraced these ecclesiastical synod's
and the Catholic world has unanimously
submitted to the infallible decrees of
the General Counsel's these concepts are
technical and abstract but Gibbon does
his best to be fair-minded he has real
respect for the intelligence and
sincerity of the disputants at Nicaea if
not for their reasoning whole national
groups would continue to espouse
Arianism in the ancient world not
necessarily because of philosophical
conviction but as a convenient weapon
against the orthodox Trinitarians of the
east the Vandals who we will see
conquering Spain and eventually North
Africa were unrepentant Aryans Gibbon
puts it very plainly a metaphysical
argument became the cause or pretense of
political contests the champion of the
Trinitarians was Athanasius
archbishop of alexandria in egypt and
suddenly a truly memorable character
appears on the scene this time a
champion of the church Gibbon gives
atthenes yes nearly 50 pages and his
account is highly positive he respects
the Archbishop's heroic sincerity and
fighting for his cause and is deeply
impressed by his leadership abilities it
would be hard to imagine warmer praise
than this
we have seldom an opportunity of
observing
either an active or speculative life
what effect may be produced or what
obstacles may be surmounted by the force
of a single mind when it is inflexibly
applied to the pursuit of a single
object the immortal name of Anthony
Zaius will never be separated from the
Catholic doctrine of the Trinity to his
defence he consecrated every moment and
every Faculty of his being at times the
Aryans got the upper hand and ethany
seus endured long periods at exile but
he never gave him Gibbon is paying best
possible compliment according to his own
values when he concludes
ethany giuse what have made a superb
emperor amidst the storms of persecution
the Archbishop of Alexandria was patient
of labour jealous of Fame careless of
safety but although his mind was tainted
by the contagion of fanaticism
Athanasius displayed a superiority of
character and abilities which would have
qualified him far better than the
degenerate sons of Constantine for the
government of a great monarchy on this
let's let Cardinal Newman have the last
word
Etha neisha stands out more grandly and
Gibbon than in the pages of the orthodox
ecclesiastical historians